all right so maybe you've seen zack
snyder's justice league by now we're
gonna get a little spoilery but before
we do i want to thank the sponsor of
this video this video is brought to you
by skillshare skillshare is an online
learning community where millions come
together to take those next steps into
their creative journey whether you're
exploring new skills or taking a deeper
dive into an already existing passion
all creative endeavors like illustration
graphic design photography animation
creative writing music
and so much more and for my fellow
cinephiles out there yes they do have
classes on film and video
interesting deep dives from creating a
modern cinematic documentary to indie
filmmaking getting the blockbuster look
on a diy budget
very interesting very helpful and as
always skillshare is curated for the
passion of learning so you're not
bogged down with ads just a creative
world of passion and possibilities
an annual subscription to skillshare is
less than ten dollars a month and the
first 1000 of my subscribers to click
the link below we'll get a free premium
skillshare trial membership you gotta
love free
you gotta love premium so click the link
below to journey the endless path of
passion and possibility and thank you
once again to skillshare for sponsoring
this video
i do appreciate it alright now since
i've already done my review of zack
snyder's justice league we're going even
deeper
with the spoiler talk of zack snyder's
justice league that's a spoiler warning
for this video now's your time to bounce
if you don't want spoilers now's your
time to stay if you don't care but as is
the case with every spoiler talk this
isn't going to be a play-by-play of the
movie to some things that stood out to
me
in the spoiler territory also as is the
case with every video
i'm gonna upload this video going oh
should have talked about that
but i forgot such as live first of all i
love how the snyder cut starts out
how it's not with some cell phone
footage with a kid and superman talking
because you know it has to be
kid-friendly it's a comic book movie
right no it starts out with superman
dying i like how
zack snyder's justice league starts out
with the end of batman vs superman
and the beginning of batman vs superman
starts out with the end of man of steel
each one feeds into the other it makes
it feel like
one odyssey so a couple things to
address here that i didn't address
in my spoiler free review so these
aren't actually spoilers first of all
the movie being four hours i do hit that
point i'm like hey it's four hours long
is it long
yes but is it worth it yes but one thing
i didn't talk about is how
quickly the four hours does fly by also
cyborg
yeah cyborg is the heart and soul of
this movie in a movie like this you're
gonna have that one character it's like
all right i'm the heart and soul i'm
kind of the audience i'm new to this
whole situation so the audience is
seeing the situation through my eyes or
at the very least they're more
emotionally attached to me
that's cyborg and i like how they
illustrate like how broken he
is in this digital day and age again
he's a digital guy
like oh superman's so powerful
absolutely not going to argue that but
can superman
shift the balance of power in terms of
financial structure
and launch a nuclear holocaust with a
thought no we can't and when the movie
was illustrating this i was like oh i'd
love to see a cyborg movie you can
show how he you know allocates funds to
this person's bank account he wants to
help people out and he immediately did
that in the movie and it was like
yeah like that but it's cyborg's
conflict between
himself him and his father it's the
heart and soul of this whole movie
and cutting it is a crime which prompted
me to do one thing
revisit the justice league before making
this video
and holy [ __ ] that is wild it's just
crazy to see the differences in scenes
like that scene where batman
like ties that guy up guys like what do
you want he's like fear
they can smell it and it brings the
parademons who apparently when the
parademons die
their blast damage on the wall makes
three mother box designs and batman's
like
good information to have you know csi
blood spatter experts out there like if
only it was that easy if only blood
spatter on the wall would just
print the name of the killer between
that action sequences
and scenes in general just being trimmed
down to a point where it's like
you have just left one extra minute in
there then the theatrical cut like
wonder woman stops that robbery from
happening
and the things that were shaved off were
just it was wonder woman being a badass
it was a much better character
introduction in zack snyder's justice
league for wonder woman
i mean that just goes without saying i
don't know why it was cut short you
could have just
kept an extra 30 seconds 10 15 seconds
in there where she's just
wrecking these dudes i don't know why it
was cut short maybe it's just like well
strictly speaking they probably didn't
live through that but we can't have
people die in a superhero movie or
something maybe it's cause it's like no
it's two zack snyder the way she was
moving like the kryptonians and man of
steel move point is that action sequence
being shaved down it's like what you
saved one extra minute it's like
i feel like the theatrical cut of
justice league there was a hard time
stamp given it's like you cannot have
this movie go over two hours not by one
minute it's like things were shaved like
but
can i just spend an extra 30 seconds no
all right and that's just how it had to
go down
even when flash is gearing up like okay
i can run and make a charge and
hit the mother box and i can create the
charge to bring superman back to life
it's so much more intense than the
snyder cut victor stone gets this
image of doom and gloom and this horrid
future that bruce wayne's having visions
of justice league buildings crumbled
superman's hardcores clutching
what looks like singed bones of who is
probably lois lane dark side giving him
a
pat on the shoulder like it's okay i
care
or don't so he says no and flesh was
like go
boom and he runs and even says like
things weird things happen with time
when he goes that fast
and so that's why in the theatrical cut
that picture of jonathan kent hits the
liquid and stinks it's like why was that
picture there
in the snyder cut the picture's there so
you can see the picture go backwards
when time
starts going backwards granted the
mother box goes backwards too but it's a
piece of alien attack there would be
that
question like did time go backwards or
is that just kind of how the mother box
happens
did it only happen with the mother box
so the audience kind of needs an
inanimate object that we know how it
reacts to
you know space time we know how a photo
reacts to gravity and space time so when
we see it going backwards
we know some weird [ __ ] is happening
so the picture dropping into the liquid
is actually a relevant thing
i'm kind of jumping around a little bit
i apologize for that just kind of how my
brain works which is probably why i
always forget to talk about something
in these videos but talking about
steppenwolf yeah i already said he was
much more badass but
i mean after after revisiting
the justice league it's just kind of i
forgot how much of an oedipus complex
this guy had for those mother boxes
in the joss whedon cut i mean zack
snyder's justice league he flexes and
breaks the arrows in his armor and his
muscles just flips horses
i'm a badass and the justice league is
all like mother
i love you so much mother we will do it
mother
i do it for you please mother
kiss it just the tip
please mother i was like oh my god
that guy really wants to [ __ ] his
mother's box i'd forgotten like
that's one of the reasons like he feels
so much more badass
in the snyder cut than the justice
league because he doesn't want to have a
4g with him in three boxes that and his
dialogue's better his look is more
badass and you feel for the guy it's
like oh
darkseid thinks you're a [ __ ] up i just
you want to go back home
i appreciate a villain like that and i
appreciate a movie that illustrates that
that is a villain like that but even
some of the jokes like some of the jokes
that weren't
in the snyder cut i thought were in the
trailers
when zack snyder was still at the helm
of justice league like i thought when
gordon says that he tells batman it's
good to see you playing with others
again
i thought that was in a trailer when
zack snyder was still at the helm and
aquaman's like dressed like a bat
i can dig it and he's like might be
temporary but that joke isn't in the
snyder cut as well as when bruce wayne's
face to face with arthur curry and he's
like arthur curry i heard you could talk
to fish
i thought that was under zack snyder but
those jokes aren't it might have been a
case where
zack snyder was like i had those jokes
but now people associate
cheesy jokes with joss whedon's justice
league cut
so i'm just gonna pull him out i know
that or joss whedon what had people come
back
and just for the sake of filming a joke
like when arthur curry tells bruce wayne
have you heard a man stronger alone he's
like
no i haven't that's the opposite of what
the saying is same with the flash in his
brunch joke when he was like i don't
have friends like i don't understand
people like like brunch what is brunch
you're in line for an hour so you're
essentially just having lunch which i
have to humor that joss whedon was like
all right
come back ezra miller brunch go make
jokes
cut perfect all right we really needed
that even the pickups of bruce wayne
starting his car when barry allen gets
in the car with him when he's like i'm
rich and you see him start the car and
his hands are on the wheel like even
those shots are different
like did joss whedon have to make them
different he's like nah i just want to
see him hit the pedal
for the gear shift or is it now it's
like 2021 you need to have the interior
of the car look
modern i don't know so those were
pickups that zack snyder did
recently who knows volco's in it i like
that dude i like willem dafoe being
in it because it was like hey we're
we're setting up a universe here
this is the setup amber heard is she
british apparently
british amber heard british meras in
this movie freaked me out again watching
the justice league i
flipped through i was like it feels like
an accent comes and goes but her
r's are definitely like american ours
zack snyder's justice league she's like
there are villains of salts put the
kettle on is wild even
at the end of this movie she's i'm like
she's still british it's not like the
accent went away i did like how mara
used her power how i've wanted to see
mera use her power
which is she can control water so
technically speaking she could leech the
liquids in the blood out of your body
and what does she do to steppenwolf
exactly that was that
in the joss whedon cut no steppenwolf
just has her against the wall and he's
like you know what i'm just gonna throw
you to the ground
cuz no he throws her to the ground
because she starts sapping the blood and
liquid out of his face
he's like nope that hurt i always
wondered why she doesn't do that
glad she did that thank you zack snyder
thank you for having mera use her powers
in a way that anyone
who has a superpowered being attacking
them would use that power
i will say this too when wonder woman's
giving the backstory to bruce wayne when
she's like okay
back in the day there were mother boxes
and bruce wayne's like mother boxes i
don't know what that is
because i haven't seen any parademons
explode on the wall and imprint three
mother boxes there wasn't a convenient
painting
where arthur curry was with mother boxes
because that was just kind to be
ridiculous but i like when she's giving
that story this was the moment
it really hit me as to what the justice
league was it actually
enhanced my perception of them or at
least took my perception
back to what my perception of the
justice league was
when i was younger she's given the story
about how dark side came to earth and
everyone got together the atlanteans uh
the world of men
the old gods the lanterns the amazons
everybody they all got together to fight
off dark side and earth is
the world that he did not get he lost
his world who shows why he's like but
just from ego he's like
i want that world it shows my
steppenwolf's like if i'm gonna get back
into his good graces i'll get him the
world that he lost
but what i liked about it was you get
the feeling like oh these gods came
together and
fought off an evil god and now the
justice league getting together
they're literally the new gods that's
what they are it's what the justice
league is so that backstory that wonder
woman gives and that connection that i
made between
the gods of old fighting dark side and
these
new gods the justice league who will
have to fight darkseid it's their rite
of passage into being the new gods again
like i said in my sport of the free
review
of zack snyder's justice league things
were implied in the justice league
but the landing wasn't stuck the
connection wasn't made because it was
just kind of exposition word vomit not
carrying you through a story it wasn't
storytelling i was glad that this movie
took me back mentally to a time when i
saw the justice league
as the new gods i was like oh we're here
again
i don't know there's like this youthful
excitement so when superman comes back i
was actually glad that the semen flashes
running around superman superman looks
at him
i'm glad that that was in the snyder cut
because i love that scene but it's the
same kind of gist he comes back and he's
like oh i'm kind of freaking out i don't
remember who i am and
so they fight although that scene when
batman gets smacked up against the car
and he's like oh
something's definitely bleeding i'm like
that that was joss whedon
no way anyone's going to tell me it
wasn't and it was not in this movie
and also it's not just like you don't
see a portal it was like oh
i guess he got the last mother box that
sucks no it shows him going after the
mother box it shows joe morton get it
and at first he sacrifices himself and i
was like oh they just durotanned him you
know like he sacrifices himself for
nothing because he's still got the
motherbox steppenwolf still wins well
that was a stupid death but you're
supposed to think that because what he
did was he marked it because he made it
the hottest thing on earth and they were
like oh we can track that he sacrificed
himself to mark the mother box
smart so yeah superman hangs out in the
farm with lois which the whole like lois
is the key thing i got the feeling it
was just like lois is the key
all right well batman brings lois to the
superman fight
and it's like oh that calms him down
lois is the key i got the feeling that's
what they were going for and that's not
it the whole lois is the key thing
that is still out there that is still
yet to come another reason i hope they
do sequels and continue this universe
anyhow superman supes shows up in his
black suit which is a
much more boss entrance steppenwolf
swings his axe smacks superman's
shoulder he's like
not impressed freezes it with his breath
and then shatters his axe how is that
not rad
are you telling me joss whedon was like
i have a better way to do it
weird and in the end the portal opening
up darkseid's there steppenwolf gets his
head sliced off like
that's way better than oh his axe is
shattered
you smell that fear oh and all the
parademons start attacking it like get
[ __ ] what and also anti-climactic
feeling
anyhow also yeah flash at the end of
this movie way more important
he saves the world the world like they
win darkseid wins and when that happened
i was like
holy [ __ ] you know what i mean like i
thought the movie was just gonna end
there like i guess darkseid won
guess the next movie will happen but
knowing the world ends the flash is like
all right i gotta run
really fast and he runs fast he reverses
time and he
undoes it like
why was i mean of all this [ __ ] to cut
out
no no i'll just have steppenwolf go down
because parademons attack him because he
feels fear
that's not cooler than the flash
reversing time it's not and flash has
more to do here he has something
important to do not saying
saving a family that was clearly filmed
as a pickup
and just they put in the truck and flash
has to get the truck to safety
good job flash you got your newbie task
of the day
no instead of that he saves the world
that's
that's what the justice league is
supposed to feel like you're supposed to
feel like yep
all of them were necessary for the grand
scale of saving the world and they all
do so the movie leaves off with this
epilogue bruce wayne is hanging out
in his pretty sweet modern [ __ ] and
martian manhunter shows up which
i think this was about i think all the
epilogue stuff i feel like zack
schneider was like i'm gonna
film more which is funny because that
dude who was martian manhunter
he was in man of steel and he was like
oh
earth's under attack let's see how the
new guy does
oh we'll just see how he does i don't
want to blow my cover or anything i mean
if superman didn't pull it off and zod
won was martian manhunter gonna be like
shoulda jumped in there oh well life
regrets right no need to look back you
just gotta keep looking forward
i'll keep looking forward as we're all
kneeling before zod
and the scene where deathstroke meets
jesse eisenberg's lex luthor
looks like this was the original filmed
version
and then the joss whedon cut just had an
extra scene it was really close to lex
luthor's face probably because it's like
all right jesse eisenberg we got him
back so it's just like all right
maybe we should start a league of our
own but this one's
way cooler because it's deathstroke like
it's personal between batman
point is deathstroke wants to go after
batman because it's personal
lost his eye to him or something which
was probably filmed at the time they
were planning the movie the batman where
deathstroke was going to be the bad guy
it was going to be ben affleck it's it's
all different now
so that post-credit scene i don't know
how much relevance it has
but it's cool that it's there you know
it's cool to see
little glimpses of like oh what shoulda
woulda coulda and the batman dreams are
back the batman dreams aren't dreams
they're visions they're reality
you get the feeling the world's gonna
end and darkseid's going to win which is
kind of
awesome and i want to see that on the
big screen
deathstroke's there british meras there
they're all there they're there with
jared leto's joker
which i don't know why he's there i'm
actually intrigued as to why he's there
i'm more intrigued as to why
joker is with batman than jared leto's
joker being there
when i was watching this scene i'll be
honest with you i was like
it still does feel like jared leto's
joker i mean his design's better he is
more calm though so i'll give him that
he's not
it's not like he's trying so hard but
you know when he laughs he's still like
and i still heard jim carrey in there a
couple times now that i have anything
against jim carrey
crushed it as dr robotnik not even being
facetious i thought he was great in that
movie
i think jim carrey is great in general
but the joker sounds a little jim carrey
in this movie which he also sounded a
little jim carrey asian some scenes
suicide squad so i kind of linked the
two together i'm like okay jared leto
still
sounds and acts like jared leto's joker
but like i said i'm less interested in
oh
jared leto's joker then i'm like why is
joker with batman
even batman's like i will [ __ ] kill
you but i'm not gonna lie that scene
with jared leto's joker
it's not like i was like oh completely i
want him as a joker forever now i
suppose he has an uphill battle
to get fans on his side and just wasn't
enough to do that so we'll see where it
goes but yeah i
i hope they go on with this universe you
know
even if zack snyder doesn't direct it i
want to see this story
where darkseid comes to earth because he
is coming he's like
we will do the old ways oh like a
full-on invasion it's happening he's
coming because he learned the anti-life
equation the ability to manipulate all
life across the multiverse not
universe no multiverse that's on earth
pretty high stakes there
i want to see that play out the justice
league has come together
they they've earned their right to be
the new gods taking on
this god conqueror it's also easter eggs
for the atom i guess the adam will
either be in the next justice league
movie or get his own movie and these are
interesting things like shazam's part of
the universe now
it could be great man it could be really
good but something
lois lane dies and it's like injustice
with
dark side as part of it like i said i
feel like the marketing campaign for
this movie overcooked the whole dark
side thing which
i kind of get though they have to show
you hey this is a different movie
it feels different it's not just
steppenwolf with a new design
here's some dark side imagery but you
can tell darkseid in this movie it was a
slow reveal they start mentioning him
they talk about him a bit
and then you see darkseid and then
darkseid's like i'm coming at the end
that [ __ ] would have melted mines if you
saw that in the movie theater and that's
how it's supposed to be you could tell
that said i saw it this way
i really want to see darkseid gun want
to see all of i won't see superman snap
or not it's like superman's going to
snap and flash is going to have to run
back and you know undo it or something
or run
back and give bruce wayne the message
the thing i really appreciated about
zack snyder's justice league is
it had humor in it but it was spaced out
in context for the tone it didn't make
it flip
into feeling like a comedy it had humor
like after flash trips
aquaman and superman dodges flash
aquaman just points at him like you
he's like i am so sorry a comedic moment
once in a while in an otherwise
darker toned movie that's completely
fine but you don't want to overdo it
make it feel like oh we're watching a
comedy now
zack snyder's justice league didn't do
that yeah zack snyder's justice league
it's good stuff i'm not just happy zack
snyder got to show his movie i am happy
for that
but i'm happy i got to see it and i'm
happy i got to see it i'm happy i liked
it alright so zack snyder's justice
league have you seen it what did you
think about it and what's it
spoilers in the comments section talk
about all the spoiler stuff whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]
you